نقلنا قبل قليل مشاهدينا الكرام في خبر
عاجل عن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قوله
انه اجرى اتصالا مطولا اليوم مع رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ولم
يطلب منه وقفا لاطلاق النار نرحب بضيفنا
هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
دكتور خليل مرحبا بك نبدا بهذا الخبر الذي
اكد فيه الرئيس الامريكي المؤكد واعاد
التذكير بالموقف الامريكي من هذه الحرب
يعطي حريه مطلقه لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو بالاستمرار في هذه الحرب الى امد
لا افق له رغم ان هذا يمكن ان يضر بفرص جو
بايدن في الانتخابات الامريكيه المقبله
كيف نفهم هذا اهلا بك محمود وبكل الساده
المشاهدين نفهم ذلك في اطار الدعم
الامريكي غير المحدود لاسرائيل هذا الدعم
هو يعتبر التزام تاريخي امريكي تجاه
اسرائيل هناك اكثر طبعا وضوحا في الحاله
الحاليه مع اداره بايدن هناك رهان امريكي
من بايدن على اسرائيل في هذه المساله هناك
اعتقاد بانه دعم اسرائيل يعتبر جزء مهم
جدا اولا في حملاته الانتخابيه القادمه
بنتكلم على ان هناك لوبي صهيوني داعم جدا
ومؤثر جدا في الاخبات الانتخابات
الامريكيه نتكلم على وجود مزادات من قبل
الجمهوريين عليه وبالتالي هناك حاجه
لابراز اكبر قدر من الدعم كي يتفادى اي
انتقاد جمهوري حتى هذه اللحظه هناك علم
يبدو دعم متماسك داخل كونجرس الامريكي
باعتباره اهم مؤسسه تشريعيه امريكيه
وبالتالي هناك التزام من بايدن باتجاه
اسرائيل المشكله الرئيسيه هنا انه هذا قد
يكلفه الانتخابات القادمه لماذا اولا هناك
بالفعل حاله انقسام شديده جدا سواء داخل
الشارع الامريكي فيما يتعلق بهذه المساله
هناك رفض على مستوى الشارع لدعم بايدن غير
محدود لاسرائيل رنا هذا الامر من خلال
استطاعات للراي خلال الفتره الماضيه على
الاقل ثلاثي الشعب الامريكي الامريكي
يرفضون هذا الدعم غ غير المطلق او غير
المحدد لاسرائيل غير المحدود لاسرائيل راد
انقسام في الحزب الديمقراطي داخليا راينا
حتى عرائض من موظفين امريكيين يرفضون هذا
الدعم غير المحدود لاسرائيل وبالتالي هناك
خساره بالفعل الاكثر من ذلك محمود هناك
خساره على مستوى الصوت العربي والمسلم
هناك بالفعل حاله رفض شديده في ولايات
مؤثره جدا كمتش جن وهي يعتبر ولايه مهمه
يطلق عليها ولايه متارجحه قد تحسن
الانتخابات الامريكيه القادمه وبالتالي لو
خسرها بايدن قد يخسر الانتخابات القادمه
خاصه في مواجهه ترامب كما نتوقع جميعا
يعني حينما نسمع الى الرئيس الامريكي
وتصريحاته المتكرره التي يرفض فيها وبحزم
تهجير سكان غزه وتغيير جغرافيه القطاع نجد
شيئا من العجب حينما نشاهد سياساته على
ارض الواقع التي يطلق فيها يد نتنياهو
ليفعل ما يريد ونتنياهو بالفعل يقوم
بتغيير التركيبه السكانيه وتغيير الاوضاع
الجغرافيه لقطاع غزه فيما يعرف بالمنطقه
العازله التي ينوي اقامتها ينوي الجيش
الاسرائيلي اقامتها على ارض القطاع
وستستعيد
يعني قطعه معتبره من ارض القطاع ربما ثلث
القطاع باكمله او نصفه كيف نفهم هذا
التناقض نفهم هذا في اطار ان هناك تناقد
واضح جدا في موقف امريكا محم هذه الحرب
اولا تناقد على المستوى السياسي هناك كما
تفضلت وقلت هناك حديث كثير حول فكره عدم
مثلا الاداره لمدنيين عدم وجود ا يعني
تهجير لكن ايضا هناك دعم عسكري غير محدود
يعني معظم ما يتم اطلاقه والقاه على
الفلسطينيين هي عباره عن قنابل امريكيه
صواريخ مجنحه دعم عسكري غير محدود جسر جوي
عسكري على الاقل خلال اخر شهرين بنتكلم
على اكثر من 200 رحله عسكريه امريكيه
لاسرائيل وفي نفس الوقت يطالب بتقليل حجم
الضرر لدى المدنيين يعني العرب
والفلسطينيين ياخدوا كلام وال الجانب
الاسرائيلي ياخذ الدعم على ارض الواقع الى
حد بعيد كما قلت قبل قليل وقلت اكثر من
مره محمود هناك حاله اختطاف شبه كامل من
اسرائيل لاداره بايدن نتنياهو يتلاعب بباي
دن بشكل كبير جدا يستخدمه يستغله عسكريا
سياسيا دبلوماسيا يعني دبلوماسيا مثلا
امريكا استخدمت حق النقد اكثر من ثلاث
مرات لمنع اي حديث حول وقف اطلاق النار
كيف يعقل ذلك فيضل الحديث حول عدم الرغبه
في احتلال القطاع مره اخرى في الحديث حول
تقليل التكلفه المدنيه في قطاع غزه ادعنا
قبل قليل خبرا عن الرئيس الايراني وبثت
وكاله رويترز خبرا مفاده ان الرئيس
الايراني اجرى اتصالا بالرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي وناقشه الوضع في غزه وعوده
العلاقات وهو اول اتصال هاتفي يجري بين
الرئيسين هناك تحركات على مستوى المنطقه ا
هناك تدخل او توسع لاطراف هذه الحرب
الجبهه الشماليه في اسرائيل وكذلك جبهه
البحر الاحمر في اليمن وتهديدات الرئيس
الايراني باغلاق مناطق بعيده جدا عن
الصراع مضيق جبل طارق ووقف الملاحه في
البحر المتوسط هكذا جاء في تهديدات الرئيس
الايراني هل تعتقد ان هذا يمكن ان يسفر عن
شيء شوف محمود نحن ااء تحول استراتيجي في
المنطقه العربيه بعد ما حدث في قطاع غزه
خلال الشهرين الماضيه بنتكلم على تحول مهم
جدا اولا بنتكلم على دخول اطراف على
الصراع نحن اذاء توسع اقليمي للصراع
انتقال يطلق عليه لو انتنستي كونفليكت او
صراع منخفض التصعيد الى صراع هاي انتنستي
كونفليكت يعني صراع مرتفع نوع ما دخول
اطراف اقليميه وان كان طبعا عبر ماطلق
عليه بروكسي وور يعني حروب بالوكاله من
خلال وجود حوثيين حوثيين الان رقم صعب في
هذه الحرب ما يتعلق بالعلاقات المصريه
الامريكيه عفوا الايرانيه علاقات مهمه
هناك نوعا ما نوع من ده موضع بين الطرفين
هذا الامر اللي بيبدا اليوم بدا على الاقل
قبل حوالي عام ونصف من الان هناك محاوله
تطبيع بين طهران وبين القاهره لكن ايضا
جزء منه متعلق بما حدث نتيجه لهذه الحرب
التي نشهدها الان وبالتالي قد قد يسفر عن
هذه تحركات بدايه تطبيع بين القاهره وبين
طهران في المرحله المقبله